how are you doing today
i'm good thank you man very good i'm
doing excellent i want to start with
congratulations on the movie i
really enjoyed this one uh i'm always
fascinated about learning
behind the scenes of the making of a
movie what do you think might surprise
people to learn about the making of a
night movie
an m night movie ah well uh well this
one in particular is a very
uh yeah this one is a particular one
because
it happens all in the beach and um and
we were shooting
in a very fantastic isolated way
the the film the story demanded that it
had to be shot like that but at the same
time uh
shooting these days and um last year
in the middle of the pandemic with so
much uncertainties and everything
it uh forced us to to shoot him in this
way as well uh where we
we had a lot of time to uh work it out
and to try out things and to um and to
wait for
for certain moments you know for the for
the tides to be correct
you know for the for the rain to
to pass us by or you know for i don't
know many many things that
that kind of uh nature sort of puts us
in that situation you know
and uh and so this is this was this was
part of the the big challenge of this
film uh
and uh and one of the biggest ones
perhaps is the premise itself
which is has to do with the fact that
time gets altered
time starts to travel really fast and uh
and knowing
and interpreting how the hell would the
characters react
to this it was a big big uh you know
it kind of i don't know was it a big
risk and a big uh
i don't know over like a very
overwhelming kind of uh
uh questioning you know completely um
knight is known for not doing a lot of
coverage and looking for very specific
shots when he is crafting his movie what
was it like working
on set with someone who's very specific
about where he wants the camera to be
and um that kind of environment uh i
i mean i really like working with
directors that
are you know like thoroughly committed
to a kind of a language that they want
to
pursue in the was making the film um
and also i i love the the economy of
frames you know uh
it's this thing that uh that you know
television has a
kind of um been an overwhelming kind of
uh
a structure of of the
of the film of the visual language and
has set that kind of a standard
in a sense uh and uh and film in a way
is it's a place where where this can you
know can
sort of you know we can exploit the the
resources of of creativity and uh
and try out different things and uh and
play with uh with different
uh outcomes you know and play with
different um
i don't know ways of of making this so
uh
he is a person that that owns a lot his
uh
his you know his semiotic er
[Music]
discourse you know there is something
that he's very good at kind of uh
playing it and defending it and uh and
you know and taking huge risks as well
which is fascinating i mean
it's very inspiring i agree
i have to stop there i'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie good luck with the
rest of your interviews
thank you thank you very much take care
have a great day